okay so I'm going to design the hardest
track I'll start with it being
anticlockwise drivers we're so used to
driving clockwise our necks are quite
strong on one side but then it's not as
strong on the other side so we're going
to start off with the long straight this
is what I'm going to call the tire
killer it's basically going to go left
and left and left and left and left I
think by this point our next are going
to be falling off as well as the tires
will explode and who doesn't like a
dangerous track I do think that would be
good for the viewers so we're going to
come into a hairpin we're going to go
back around in between that's a great
start to that with the rest of the space
what what should I do we are going to go
into a city I'm going to put a team yeah
we'll go Thailand go to my home race the
roads are are not great either so it's
going to add an element of surprise
we're going to just a very simple
hairpin it basically looks like a snail
at this point so we might as well just
keep it going keep it looking like a
snail so we're going to go basically in
between I don't know what this is these
are just chaines this is a river and
then this side is a cliff it's basically
life and death and then that's it I
think it's very simple should I name it
say rail the snail a train rail right
and it looks like a snail